Ірина Бондаренко волонтер до
ми ж що дня дівчина приходить до
госпіталю бундесверу в кобленку рахунок
Петро i mat його поранених українських вояків
сюди ду провали pleo тих важких куб у
поранених у вінні на донбасі на загартування
піку ось і вся захисником та україна бі-2
нувся сотнями безладно хрускіт в'янучи і
rhino
утен ширасу злодії карантин довелося
обмаже та coloud їх хто мужу проведу
вати хлопців регулярно у нас є своя
маленька група в facebook біля будинку
кордону та movie 2 даної voluntary якір
пройшов сьогодні кованим написати виразку
якийсь були проблеми
що хлопці хочеш що їм потрібно чим ми
можемо oem допомогти допомогти хочеш катували
у потенті в душі добре розумом і волонтерів
sl-1 сша разу приносить все ти пам'ятай
торби з магате
до остраху хочеться тихіше ти хлопців
пшемислі про з кутовим алла знайти ніші для
поранених за карти навпіл на на
телефон the internet внесені піднімаючи на
вістря тому що з тлумачення шкідливим і
українці та то вже з прийшли удушення
кажи міккі зоеллу лікарка віку впікання і
ті тріумфуванням пацієнтів з України ігор
павлів
родом з кривого рога doom убили зації
вінник алан і служить в армії
вранці of sheep біля скроні та гір та клану
місця у святу за вище в дружину та дітей
і пішов на фронт вин один із тисяч вояки
вгіке по стежках його той же не під
іловайському кулаки або проходів веселий
парад до дня на закладення йогор
стікають же кров'ю за качалком у valve
прориву вся кріс силу війська побоїще
залишився за втратив у зеленці фруктів
пососи вона стоп на вирву і встав і
мабуть кілометрі всім пройшов курс по
зайти днр до нашого найбільшого
блокпоста
тільки в бачив своїх і впав а там з до
ліпімар на пом'яті тата пологів та арія
операція німецькі лікарі плану та заміни
ти вушко джину ділянку черепа пласт іншу
а так вже пустуватий bio електронний
процес замінимо як ванни і кисті рук
та його vortice 30 тисяч євро просто виду
і лікарка
протези ніг і склепінням поставляти та
Дмитро раз ленському
2-4 особисте іноді скрючене за своїм і
військовими побратимом і по трапу в
пігментний обстріл за образом саур могили
уламком міни хлопцями лідирувала нова
біля воріт і прапора нині 1 милю бути проломи
вище задушать і стати на ноги знову град і
футбол 1 новий телефоном за маму я нині
мабуть найбільшу роль радує для юна до
а сам від метро свої вуха тираді знести
здаєте на вдихаючи всіх їм шах вигляд
медперсоналу то волонтерів я роздобув
відросток хлопці у нас поклав ось робить
і була ампутована давала мені на
even навіть усміхався і сміявся телефоном
танцювати до ми це котяча і навіщо я
члени можуть також посміхатися сміятися
18 життя режимі і тоді скошуючи доки
буду його
Дмитро розумі і його жити, а за дружину буду
так їм ягоду why me all і чи не простіше
skoda я ні секунди не шкодую буду там та
захищав свою крек крилами і здається
борг кожного захищатися ігри віктор
савчук із черкашин поверх 40 пацієнтів до
млинцю брехня в італію здається душу по
щас ти краще по трапу раптом чи німецьких
карим києві білкового
професора моя, клас можна h2000
спілкуватися вже входить і булавин, що прийшов
ти зможеш ось цей собою треба нора
нижча до уроку поруч із вектором місяця
огляди можна ході ти лика звичайно поля до
німецьким лікарям з острова популярні не в
україну
Віктор на сам парад хочу поїхати і на
могилу свого товариша я квеврі туго
обсягу жити а сам не виживши дивитися
протилежними обурені віктори боготу дума
ти про мої будні україни
опції
час на мить світлі сім'я кількох дітей
цицит вже страшно я вважаю що ці
одиниці сама письменниця коренева
дає 70 жити на чому не позначилося
щоб смертельною були
дарування було піклуватися і ролики
зв'яжіть готові зафарбувати
Дмитро Віктор
йогор
цілий і намети частки з тисяч чашку
поранених у вінні на сході
україни тріумфування у не менше не так
допоможе ліктем у пивні шоде ви тис а в
мої будні а джинан їх так району за я
ковані пролили свою кров
шику ще багата ви пробували